these cows at a breeding center enjoy
food aren't just welfare director after
they even have their own minister
otherand Abbasi comes from a traditional
cow herding community the Hindu
nationalist BJP party appointed him as
Rajasthan Scout minister India's first
three years ago his job is to make sure
the animal which is sacred to India's
Hindu majority is well protected we
considered the cow as a model we believe
that God resides water but the humble
cow has recently become India's most
polarizing animal right-wing Hindu
groups are accused of whipping up
hysteria across the country warning that
the cow is under threat Hindu bitch'll
antic groups have attacked trucks they
suspected were illegally transporting
cows to slaughterhouses organizations
like the Rashtriya Raksha dal or
national cow protection group have even
targeted restaurants for serving beef
many Hindus consider eating a taboo
given the group's firebrand Hindu leader
Kemal didi accuses Muslim traders who
dominate the meat industry of rampantly
smuggling cows on the outskirts of
Jaipur Kemal didi meets her volunteers
they tell her they rescued account from
smugglers often in formulas tipped them
off the group says this bull was
intentionally injured to make it easier
to smuggle commands IDI says she won't
shy away from violence if needed we will
do whatever it takes to save comes we
won't let cows ly slaughtered if anyone
even looks at a cow we will gouge their
eyes out we're not scared of the
consequences
the campaigns to protect cows even saw a
mob in Rajasthan recently Lynch a Muslim
farmer he later died of his injuries
these images taken on a mobile phone
sparked outrage in the country author
Ron Davis who's from the ruling BJP
party says state laws banned the
slaughter of cows and they have to be
respected if anyone is found smuggling
cows the police have to be informed and
they will take action we have made
provisions for that in Rajasthan no one
should take the law into their hands and
endanger people's lives but that has
done little to ease concerns in
Rajasthan cattle industry these traders
say the political tension over cows has
badly affected the business and struck
fear into Muslims now cattle traders are
really worried that they would be
stopped or beaten up or that the cattle
will be confiscated cradles from outside
Rajasthan are no longer coming to cattle
fears limbs are associated with
slaughterhouses and the moment you have
a Muslim name these vigilante groups
targeting they don't care if you're
innocent they just start beating you up
it's very scary actions run higher among
members of the vigilante group protect
the cow protect the nation with a shout
India's holy cow is embroiled in a very
unholy mix of religion and politics